[Music]
all right this next story
it reminds me of bart but i don't think
you'd be this
inconsiderate okay here we go so you're
saying i'm inconsiderate
like one point
it was a bad combination of words put
together i'm not saying that you are
inconsiderate i'm saying that this story
reminds me of something you have done
because the words you chose
i admitted i said it clumsy maybe but
listen
listen to this and consider it let her
insult you more thoroughly okay thank
you yes
let you let's yeah yeah okay i wasn't
trying to insult you bart i'm sorry i
apologize but listen this is the part
that reminds me of you
i consider myself considerate you are
very considerate that's why i said
you're not this considerate
that was i was trying to compliment you
it came out wrong anyway
here's what it says it says am i the
[ __ ] for being upset that my
boyfriend urinates in glasses at night
instead of using the bathroom for a
specific receptacle
or a specific reception i see the that's
what i was trying to say we both have
bathrooms in our houses i get it
okay so this is what the story says my
boyfriend has sleep issues and it's hard
for him to fall back asleep if he has to
go all the way downstairs and then back
up in the middle of the night to use the
bathroom
we are students with a third roommate
and have separate bedrooms
the first time it happened i found one
of our glasses full of urine
on his nightstand it happens every so
often now
and he sometimes let it sit there for a
day or longer
nasty bastard he kind of acknowledges
that it that it's gross
and he wouldn't like it if someone else
did it but overall he doesn't seem to
think it's a huge
deal i'm upset and grossed out every
time i see it
we have cats that could knock it over
and accidents can happen
we live in an old house with wooden
floors with huge gaps in between them so
if it spills it's sticking around
it's like a disaster waiting to happen i
try to be understanding so i've asked
that maybe he'd buy a specific mason jar
with a lid so that there's no risk of
spilling it's very nice she's actually
really nice
that's very nice can you have these pee
in a mason jar please that's very nice
she's trying to meet him halfway
yeah be a hipster about it
and i also think that it should be
flushed and washed every morning yes i
think that's a fair compromise
i've tried suggesting this but he just
continues to use glasses that are left
over from drinking water in his room
and acts like a victim when i get upset
about it
i truly don't feel that i'm overreacting
but i'm trying my best to see it from
all sides here
am i the [ __ ] she is trying she is
really trying to see
understanding he's [ __ ] nasty
and [ __ ] immature for acting like a
victim so i do pee in bottles and stuff
sometimes wait in the house
still friends don't judge me but the
[ __ ] i just asked the question and i'm
not gonna answer
the bathroom's very far away i have been
to your house no it's not
there's literally a bathroom there's
literally a bathroom in every
section you would congregate it is a
pretty far walk though
joe shut the [ __ ] up anyways um i
wouldn't know but i always i only pee in
things that i'm gonna throw away
i don't pee in a glass though i'm gonna
drink
okay the word this is what the rudolph i
apologize i take back the word this
you're not inconsiderate thank you
that's what i meant you meant he pees in
jars and [ __ ]
that's what i meant in just one of these
though don't you need more than one
sometimes you need more than one he
often wait and then pull up another one
it's like dumb and dumber
remember yeah it's like that i think
yeah you pinch it off real quick
get the other bottle start going again
when i really need to pee though
i can't pinch off i can't do that it
hurts my [ __ ] child
like the movie when was last time you
tried peeing in a bottle do you always
like
like do you have to grab a second bottle
in the meantime the last time i tried
you didn't you couldn't do
it yeah that's why i never did it again
oh
yeah because i thought i'd be able to
finish i don't think i've ever had an
overflow
problem with it it's always been in the
car though yeah because
you're not you're not a strong peer it's
okay to be in the non-strong pier
okay think about it dude you got this
i've never i've never compared my p
levels to another person's
let's say you drink this much right
that's more liquid
than this i don't know much yeah
orbs part of it i don't know if it works
like that joe i'm just saying that if
you could drink multiple of those
and you got to pee it's coming out it's
coming out
more than that not math not nelson i i
got i guess i've also never tried using
like a normal bottle normally like
i've ever oh you go big huh well good
for you bro i do
it's a little bit safer because i'm
saying that that's a small bottle
if i'm on a road trip i always think of
like you grab like gatorades on a road
trip
and those have a big mouth those are i
like those ones because you could just
stick your dick
directly into the bottle no baby you
shouldn't say that because maybe steve
can't
so maybe you should i think everybody
can i got heavy flow over here okay
yeah a big pier over here yeah i think
that the bottle
that's a baby bottle yeah this bottle
this bottle i don't know if i've ever
tried it yeah taika would fill that up
what do you use that like uh those
like when you get your urine tested two
liter bottles oh
well those ones you get a little cup and
so you just pee over the toilet and as
soon as you finish it yeah you just go
you go you start in the cup yeah and
then you go like that
well i think you're supposed to pee a
little i don't know for guys but for
girls you're supposed to pee a little
bit
out first and then put the cup because
like that first initial pee they don't
want
what they've never told you that i've
never heard that
they've never told me told me that when
i when i was pregnant and i was going
and doing a [ __ ] ton of urine tests
they would tell me that chicks are
disgusting wait the
the ones that brought you into this
world those are disgusting yeah
we don't want that you reap through a
clearing key yeah that
it's like some [ __ ] like that or i'm
like what the [ __ ] i have to like
pee and then catch it in my whole
[ __ ] hands all right
you got peepee all over your hands
probably i'm assuming
i remember health class when they
described the [ __ ] as like a biome i
was like
what the [ __ ] you don't want to go
courses well no it was just
it's the worst way to explain something
that it has like a [ __ ] that's fun
flora and fauna and [ __ ] it sounds like
a magical place once you enter
like below the hips though don't you
feel like you're an alien planet and it
just looks so different
like it's a creature of its own enter
with what your penis or your eyes your
eyes
when you when you look be below and then
you see
that privates and you go you know what's
crazy though
like really really really crazy because
right now i'm in the middle of reading
this one book where it like really talks
about
women's bodies and like how the fact
that we are all
men and women where all the same parts
just rearranged in different ways
is that anatomy book no it's called come
as you are it's a really good c-u-n
so sick when me i'm measuring we all
learned that in anatomy though
no yeah so no but like they go into like
how women's sexuality
like it's really really good um but the
thing that blew my mind
which i didn't really know because i
didn't know about how like your ovaries
or
your guys like testes and all that stuff
but you know that
line that you have in the ball sack yeah
you know if you guys were
women yeah that line turns into your
labia majora
oh cool yeah so like you tell me i have
labia
don't you don't don't tell me ball sex
skin is the same
skin that it would dude your dick is
outside in [ __ ]
it is it's it's an audi [ __ ] dude
you're you got a [ __ ] you got a big ass
you're a big [ __ ] man
and you have a really big [ __ ] you're
outies those are 80s and we're outies
and it hangs low i heard that's what i
mean if i was a girl i'd be one of the
dark [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right you do have a dark [ __ ] i
have a dark because i have dark balls
mm-hmm so what happened
we put that together yeah
your balls are darker than your dick
yeah you want to see them are they
i don't forget yes oh i've seen it i
just didn't recognize
we've all seen it yeah oh where did you
see it
hot sauce sticky pie is all i gotta say
yeah cause i'm like you don't
go naked with that no no no i saw it
covered in hot sauce
was it shaved or not yeah it was covered
in hot sauce
in a cup of milk yes i saw that on my
computer
over and over again you were editing the
when he peed on the t-shirt
no when he uh when he dipped his balls
in the middle oh i apologize
at the camera the time he's like hey pat
pat come here
did a pet zoom in no he's like oh [ __ ]
he moved away
but you went in slow-mo uh i had to uh
because i i did
two versions one where i cut it out and
one where i blurted
over it oh so you really had a stair
yeah you were tracking the ball options
you know
and yeah i had to trap the balls
professional
yeah and then you could hear geo in the
background and be like oh why
sounds about right damn we honestly if i
was this girl's
like if i was this girl trying to be
this inconsiderate
with this boyfriend i honestly i would
not know how to get him stopped the
worst part is that it's he's not even
like putting it on the floor it's on the
nightstand
so when you wake up in the next morning
it's eye level with you you know
and that's also nose level with you yeah
that's the thing
you can of course you can smell it that
that's the worst that's a pippy smell
or he's not even buying containers that
are made to purposely throw it away
yeah the thing that grosses me out the
most the fact that they're using these
cups to
drink yeah he's still drinking why can't
he just walk to the bathroom though
yeah i'm not letting this [ __ ]
sleep on the bed i'm gonna be like you
need to fix your [ __ ] self and then
you come
in or just sleep downstairs just sleep
downstairs though he has to be a child
it's like
okay no more liquids two hours before
you go to bed how high
baby nobody and awesome does this guy
have to be where you would put up that
kind of [ __ ]
because this girl is obviously staying
with them for some
magical reason because when all of us
hear this
we will not want to partner that [ __ ] if
i if i wake up middle of night and i
heard nikki fill in jars up
next to me oh my god that would look so
funny though because you guys can at
least stand but a girl has to be like
hovering she's gonna be hovering on the
bed over you like punched over
we could still lay down and do it
all right just wedge it up there and
then you could get go hands-free too
if you needed to you know work if you're
holding a baby
you guys know how to do it the right way
wait how does that work you screw it in
like a light bulb yeah right
[Laughter]
wow you should read this book that i'm
talking about guys you need to read this
book
oh dude girls should get that funnel you
know that that that peepee funnel
yeah that then they could pee in bed but
i think they make it for girls right but
it's gross because then you have to
rinse it and
like no you just toss it no they're not
disposable no i mean like
rinse it later you could be i'm just
trying i'm just trying to give you an
option so you could challenge the
grossness you know what i mean
when you have kidney stones i got an
idiot oh please no go first no you have
to try to catch the stone so they give
you a filter thing to pee into
but you have to like put it why do you
have to catch it just so you know they
want to analyze it
so yeah you have to like feel it getting
closer to the edge and like ah quick
that's the hope right yeah so whatever
going on roller coasters i heard that
that actually helps
like [ __ ] you that's ridiculous no for
real that's ridiculous
okay but you have to put the receptacle
down somewhere
because you have to use the filter until
you get it out so it's super [ __ ]
disgusting to have it like out in your
bag
peeing through like a like a sift like a
look like a metal
filter like a tee steeper honestly
this time around with my stone i didn't
do it like like two years ago when i had
him they're like we know what your
stones look like
exactly ten years ago though i had to do
that it sucked wait so you're peeing
directly in the toilet but you have a
a mesh you're peeing through a filter
thing yep but into the toilet
yeah why would they need to analyze it
or they're like this one has a lot of
calcium and red bull
right tomato maybe to see if it's
breaking up and there's little particles
in it
like passing they want to see if it's
glowing from all the monsters like this
one's magnesium
thank you nelson cause you listened to
me i wouldn't buy red bull unless it was
on sale
it's monsters it was diet red bull it
was diet red bull
they would be diet red bull or white
monsters white monsters yes
yes two for three or those off-brand
ones when you're really desperate that's
what i'm always
that's actually if the deal is there oh
it's so funny what was your idea
oh yeah what was it oh okay so come back
in uh so the idea would be i guess to
get to get him to stop is pretty [ __ ]
up but
i mean you got to do what you got to do
in uh uh when you want it to stop so
i would get his [ __ ] cup and if he's
gone in the morning i'm going to put it
on the [ __ ] mattress
i'm going to probably suffer but like
pour that on his side
yeah on his side i'm like that's what
you wanted the cat did it are you happy
he sounds like a disgusting [ __ ]
but
okay like you wouldn't even care it was
disgusting
i gotta think about it again whoa whoa
trying to be nice i usually pee in the
bed but
exactly if you want to just go back to
the old place i'm down
i'll go back to the old ways okay i got
everything a gentleman for you but hey
be a criminal you gotta catch you gotta
think like
i mean okay back to the drawing board
all right my bad i wasted your time
that's so funny
[Music]
foreign
[Music]